hey what's up
we can thank you
so now all eyes back on the fourth year
man Hopkins he did miss one earlier from
42 everyone this is Peter Brown standing
in for reviewer Miguel concepción for
his review of Madden NFL 17 between an
improved running game and welcome
changes to the defensive line ea sports
latest Madden NFL game not only provides
more tools to become a well-rounded
playmaker but also the means to execute
more decisive plays a significant launch
week bug and lack of online co-op are
just two of the issues that prevent it
from being a complete Madden experience
but that doesn't hold back Madden 17 for
making you feel like a complete Madden
player franchise mode remains the trusty
single-player campaign that lets you
show devotion to a team over multiple
seasons thankfully the roster UI has
been improved over last year's
unremarkable interface which now
features prompts for roster cut downs
and recommendations on who to trade cut
and sign this saves considerable time
while you make key week-to-week
adjustments during a season the main
draw whether you're in this mode as a
player or owner is in seeing the impact
of your decisions over the course of a
season whether it's key trades or
changes to concession prices there's a
sense of responsibility with every
choice you make like how you address
lingering injuries in the face of a
tough opponent
Maddon 17 greatly benefits from little
tweaks and touches on the field there's
added realism to player locomotion even
for linemen who aren't handling the ball
midair swatting by a defender is a
fitting counter to an otherwise
overpowering receiving game and is
challenging finding copy and pasted
groups of fans in the crowd one of the
more obvious changes involves kickoffs
and field goals by employing a three
button input system used by most golf
games EA Tiburon shows its affinity for
tried-and-true mechanics that have been
around since the 80s unfortunately a
noteworthy multiplayer bug at launch
gives the defense too much information
during a game specifically on whether or
not they can expect a passing or running
play to come their way it's simply a
matter of whether you can see the
receivers names or not if the names are
visible while toggling the play arts
feature it's a pass play if not it's a
running play
one hopes that developer EA Tiburon will
have a patch to address this soon but
that remains unclear for people who
can't spend upwards of an hour in a
full-fledged game of football the new
play the moments mode significantly
reduces play times by having the bulk of
the game unfold via a simulation while
letting you take control on crucial
plays it's a dicey proposition to leave
the outcome of an entire Drive in the
hands of a CPU but after several tests
against unbalanced teams it's comforting
that even lowly teams like the Jets
consistently have a chance of beating
the Patriots by the half beyond the
highly accessible gameplay the skilled
trainer ensures that newcomers and
novices receive a thorough understanding
of the controls the only missing feature
is a submenu detailing the rules of
football the kind of details that would
benefit a genuine newcomer if he a tip
arounds goal with Madden 17 was to build
upon the solid foundation set by the
last two games the studio mostly
succeeded by fine-tuning its production
values on and off the field while also
focusing on its strengths in its
ultimate team in franchise modes rather
than to riding the latest Madden 4
featuring more of the same features from
previous years there's instead comfort
in the familiarity of trusted and
refined features like weekly updates and
the comprehensive skills trainer save
for the after mention play calling bug
and some long loading times this is the
most accessible and welcoming Madden in
this console generation which is an
accomplishment for a game about a sport
that can appear complicated at first
glance
you